get a lot more physical in this way yeah
very sufficient you go now to disorder
the McKenna show but it's not there from
finally first the first order is
packaging better than ever and it
requires them to make a judge decided on
it was the first moment where you were
like oh my god I missed all this movie
making a movie and it kind of hated yeah
I mean going on that set and seeing the
incredible I don't want to say
specifically what but the incredible
sets I there were some moments where I
mean I the people that work on us movie
every single person is so passionate and
just so happy to be there and when you
see these kind of things that you've
seen in a movie come to life and they're
actually there in front of you that was
the moment where I was like it might be
happening but I'm still not completely
convinced about thank you so much you
you're returning back to a world trim
them because we want to get done before
away because I we're not where the focus
should be on the game love it we're back
and being in the jacket and having to
revisit so like you will continue in a
double life that you're living strange
so how does rain relationship with
wilderness will be different from like
Luke's relationship with a builder and
well rain is not a teacher Yoda and
obi-wan are very much like guiding
students like an area and an array I
think probably you can have an energy
use which turned up like with this
frickin lightsaber that you've not seen
in however long so so that in itself is
a big difference and then as things go
I'm like I think there's an expectation
there's always been an expectation or
Luke as two potentials you can do and
what you should do
much like my brain so in that sense
they're kind of similar but obviously
the dynamic is change because she's
expecting something from him this time
and it remains to be seen with it you
know how he we asked about your
character roses mechanic yeah get roped
into this epic now okay saga right
that's the question that you're going to
have to wait till December to find out
what was your audition anymore distances
dollars yeah it was a pretty long
process I wish it went on for five maybe
six months
um it was pretty expensive but I can say
that from the beginning
marriage of casting and rise and romney
both were there they made it as lovely
as possible I mean of course as an actor
you're like who is a pretty exciting
everyone was so amazing and not feel
didn't come across as well Evaristo
percent how do you think this movie
different comfortable short version
because a lot more part if not
auditioning trying to figure out now
normally established love in one's
career and now after they are easily
clarify that 2/3 of state
how do you think this film pushes the
entire series forward maybe in a unique
way in a way that we haven't seen
install with yes I think that I spoken
to a number of people that have seen a
rough cut and everyone's like it's
different it's different so I think with
Ryan's vision and his image and also I
think he had JJ you know what all kinds
backfilling he comes in and he had a
list up and Ryan I think has more room
to kind of do his thing not that JJ
doesn't that sounds wrong but as in
there was just more rooms everything
degree it's fine the way I came into it
I feel like it's always the wrong thing
if you come in and you're driving forces
I'm gonna make something different I'm
going to throw away the pair I'm gonna
surprise people you know to me it's all
about okay
these characters that were set up in the
force awakens where does it make sense
to me that they go next
and I think if you follow that through
you'll get to some surprising places
you know because you're going to be
following where it makes sense to you
that they go next but yeah so I don't
know it's a question for me to answer
because I tried to just tell it really
on a story of where I thought these guys
should go so I think you'll find some
things that might surprise you and they
certainly surprised me
I said you're Ryan I said I think I
fundamentally disagree with pretty much
everything you've decided for me now
having said that I have to accept it get
my mind around it and do my best to
realize your vision and once I got into
it a lot of my fears were went away did
you watch the trailer inside what
there's a yeah yeah I was there for sure
then checking around I'm trying to get
this press line done some go back
favorite moment laughter America oh
right hands on the on the floor with the
stones by breaking up yeah there's our
powers burn our trailers awesome oh yeah
you like it you have a favorite favorite
moment from it I feel though this and
they were the a dancer in the distance
yeah you get a glimpse at well I love
that and I love the reveal of the read
of that kind of little hint of what that
battle on that planet is going to be
like and that's a new planet yes a new
planet yeah it's like a mineral planet
so it's salts a thin layer of salt over
like this red ruby blood-red sort of
crystal it gets dug up and you upgrade
the adults around oh you'll have to see
yeah maybe you can look at the
silhouette
it's like check it out but we yep I mean
it's yeah so that is at that moment but
I gotta say though the moment where we
come around the mountainside and reveal
you know ray and Luke in silhouette when
and I heard the audience a little kind
of like breath in the audience when that
happened I was like this makes me happy
[Music]
you
[Music]